please welcome silver medal
award-winning filmmaker kim spurla
hi
okay
uh i have something in here somewhere
hold on one second
um i just like to add to tinnell's
earlier metaphor about birthing and
filmmaking
um a mentor once told me that filmmaker
films are like children you nurture them
for a while and then you send them out
into the world and sometimes they say
what you want to and sometimes they say
something different
so i'm very very thrilled that my my
film spoke meaningfully to some of you
um with that i'd like to thank the
academy for the opportunity to be here
it's such an honor to meet and share
ideas with you and the folks at the dga
the wga and the asc and to be counted
among such a talented group of
filmmakers
i'd also like to thank all of those who
helped bring down a number five to
fruition including my family and my
community in west virginia
the nyu faculty for their guidance and
support and our intrepid cast and crew
including my dp greg bitnick
my producer
david chan
and some of those who are here including
a good portion of my cast chris
michael and andrew and my composer dika
derpazovich
and last but not least i want to thank
my beautiful sister and co-writer mai
who is also here
and my boyfriend ben for his unwavering
support of my directory fantasy
fantasies and fantasies too thank you